[Music]
special projects Nicole an alert just
came through from prism cyber terrorists
have compromised my network probably
yours as well
they're sending threats okay I'm ready
what do we know who are they it's a
group calling itself every Tay a name
gives me chills every day and vite I
don't I don't think that's a terrorist
group I paid two different listen Henry
topple you were invited to a big blowout
for Doug sincerely the Evie team now I
know what a big blowout means that means
there's a bomb under your Oldsmobile but
what does Doug mean Doug Doug Doug Doug
you've worked with him for like 30 years
it's his retirement
wait you were invited to Doug's party
and I wasn't oh god this is it my time
is done I've served by purpose they're
gonna put me down like a three-legged
horse you were invited to Doug's party
that's what the evite is about it's an
invitation to Doug's retirement party oh
well then why did prism think this was a
terror emergency maybe they're bored I
know my eyes glaze over reading Facebook
and I only have to keep up with 300
friends they have 800 million I doff my
fedora to this Facebook it's the
smartest way to keep people dumb since
we started fluoridating the water you
know we put cognitive D hamsters in the
water right and in the airplane
contrails that's why everyone who lives
by an airport is so stupid it's probably
best if you stop talking about
classified information like that now why
would that be every time you do it I
have to fill out an ad AJ incident
report ad AJ's those are filled out by
supervisors you're not my supervisor
which brings me to my next point this
earlier I'm your supervisor I swallowed
a fax machine in Guam you're a great
asset but the world has changed we got
to keep up oh I get it
modernity must have its do all hail the
cutting-edge beep boop comm oui
back spying on you you have no right and
suppose you're gonna haze me now I was
hazed at Eton I was hazed at
skullenbones i was hazed when i signed
on with the agency but now I'm asking
you as a friend I'm asking you as a weak
old man who loves his country please
don't big baby me big baby you ya shaved
my entire body and make me wear a diaper
it's kind of hazing 101 I wouldn't do
that
googoo gaga please mommy googoo gaga
where are you at you asking me to do it
maybe a ghoul is wildly inappropriate
[Music]